time for screen junkies movie fights
what in the world I had to keep it up
just hello welcome to movie fights I am
NOT how run Nick I am your host and
moral how could not be here today so I'm
sitting in for my first time as judge on
the new receipe movie fights good times
but I'm not alone up here at the table
first sitting directly to my left he is
one of the writers modest trailers and
he is probably here because someone is
sick no I've actually booked to be Wow
Joe star the rare actually booked
appearances right fights right Joe
welcome to the show thank you Dan next
up she is one of our the new class I
like to call boobie fights the new class
she is the host of The Simpsons podcast
please welcome back Julia Prescott it's
like Highlander you kill the rest and
this is a familiar face back for another
week trying to get the win it's Cameron
Rice Cameron welcome back after my
amazing score last week goes zero back
there's something in that cake that when
it was announcer we were all on this
panel today somebody on Twitter goes
uh-huh this should be a weird one
believe it's gonna get silly I will say
real quick we don't know when you get
the question about who should play what
kind of thing we can't put unknown actor
right like the amount of times on the
con super like it needs to be an unknown
it's not a good fight fabulous I'm
picking someone you've never heard of
and they're great I am the host today
I'll also be one of the judges but the
big difference is the last time I said
in this chair is that there are two
other judges first sitting and my usual
seat
he's keeping our facts straight he's our
fact checker the professor himself Juan
Harris thank you thank you thank you be
here and next to one as always the voice
of the people my fellow Dan Daniel
Radford hello um so as you all know the
way this works is there are lots of
polls all over the on line the one that
counts for this is the pool that is on
YouTube if you have questions about how
that works it should be in the
description below ask any of us in the
chat the answers will go up once the
initial arguments have been have been
started or finished because we want the
suite based on the arguments if you
change your mind that's totally cool you
have them so up until I start saying
here's what the audience vote is because
the audience vote in the case of a tie
is our tiebreaker
I will also be on the hashtag movie
fights live you guys also have so many
amazing memes and other theories and
answers and explanations so I go through
there and comb out some of the best ones
so if you get active on bully fight slap
I might just cash out you out during the
show oh the the London Calling shout out
unicorn in the movie fights guys you've
all played the game before but just to
run down the rules in case you don't
know this is a best-of-seven games you
need four total points through both the
main round and the speed round to emerge
victorious after the three main
questions and the other day one one tie
or if somebody's gone on a tear and it's
three to nothing we will have a
tiebreaker at that point will not count
but it will carry the winner into the
speed round and that's pretty much it
you guys ready to play yeah let's do it
let's do this thing
prepare to die ladies and gents
[Music]
I just wanted to do that yeah Thank You
Thor there's my favorite part of every
week guys this is the first question
it's an oldie but a goodie this ice blue
this question harkens back to our very
first fan fight several years ago that's
that's how long we've been talking about
Wolverine it's coming back around as you
may not have heard you may or may not
know Disney and Fox are gonna become one
and the x-men are gonna be relaunched
and Disney is on the hunt for the new
Wolverine so let's just save them some
time and settle it right now about that
got it round one who should Disney cast
as the next Wolverine Cameron has
established that no one is not 100%
nailed it I'm eight would be a great
Wolverine
he is buff going by the round-robin
rules we're starting with Joe star Joe
who should Disney cast as the new
Wolverine well Dan in order
[Applause]
I don't just look like the English
teacher high school that tried too hard
I sound like the Great Gatsby school
guys in order to answer this question we
first need to address a problem and that
is the problem of Hugh Jackman Dan
Morrill because Hugh Jackman has changed
people's perception of Wolverine and so
now the PI look at any top 10 list that
any website is put out of they should
play Wolverine and it's all hunks it's
all Scott Eastwood and giant Courtney's
and is he attractive I don't know I've
never I don't remember what he looks
like
just the square-jawed just handsome
towering men and that is not what
Wolverine is damn it Wolverine is like a
4 foot 2 hairy bear that lives in the
Canadian wilderness that smells like
cigars and cheap booze and that is why
my pick is Ryan Hurst Ryan played Opie
and Sons of Anarchy
[Applause]
furry little son of a gun
Wolverine needs to be burly and mad
looking and just look a little scary
like he shouldn't it's supposed to be
weird that Jean Grey is in love with
Wolverine it's not supposed to be like
oh I get that like immediately looking
at a Hugh Jackman type this guy he's got
the anger down he's got the pathos down
and he's he's hairy enough to pull it
off Ryan Hurst underlining hairy and my
notes all right Julia noted my answer to
the question of who should be the next
Wolverine is you know such an easy gimme
to the Disney Foxx equation a little bit
more on the Disney side I of course in
picking Oscar Isaac Oscar Isaac which is
my Hall Pass to my husband Oscar Isaac
who has been wowing us through just you
know so many different characters over
the last handful of years you know he
was in that movie suburban con but
have happened but he was the best pardon
and he's often the best part in a lot of
movies and and I think that you know
he's currently like plugged into the
wall at Disney Studios somewhere because
they've got him going for all the Star
Wars stuff and I feel like yeah he's
probably renting a condo from Disney on
the studio lot right now and they can
just throw them in there so super easy
alley-oop answer juggling his duties as
Batman Oscar Isaac as well Cameron who's
your pick and a reminder you can't say
someone unknown well you can't you can't
say the word someone unknown but you can
pick someone unknown fair and to sum
this might be an actor that is slightly
unknown Wolverine I agree he's got to be
he's got to be tough he's got to look
like a mean son of a [ __ ] who's gonna
rip some people apart but there is that
side of Wolverine that is the sad lone
Ronin the one who you could believe when
he goes Yuriko you feel his Pecos and
his his heart break so my original
choice was Becky Lynch but I didn't go
with that my secondary choice and I
think this actor could pretty much pull
this off is actor Mathias I'm gonna
butcher this Scott - Harris I believe he
is a a dutch actor now some people might
go well that's Dutch she's not Canadian
I think about Wolverine is because he's
lived a long time he's traveled to many
lands and I think having done some of
that unknown accent much like your
Christopher Lam bear gives that hit some
mysteriousness to the man on top of the
fact that this actor has been in some
great movies such as bullhead and rust
and bone where he really bulked up put
on the pounds and looked like a weird
crazy mad man
Rustom bow knees up like a street
fighter he beats a lot of some people
and breaks his hands trying to break his
son out of some ice and then he's in
movies like I lost the list he's in some
other movies where he plays romantic
leads and things like that so I think he
can balance out both the mean crazy son
of a [ __ ]
and also the guy you could believe many
different women in the Marvel Universe
well in love with I'd like to point out
we're ten minutes into the show we've
already had two Highlander references
train going yeah
okay you can't use the one Highlander
joke that we use to call back highlight
Ryan Hurst we have Oscar Isaac we have
Mathias this is going score nerds one of
us had some kind of a machine in front
of us that kid is in the studio
adjusting cameras right now
framing matters people framing matters
we don't have a button for a camera that
said guys you seem a little shook Dan
because I was really hoping they would
just pick pick nothing but attractive
people and I could yell at them for it
but we've all picked sort of gritty
burly Oscars it's not a trick although
he is a treble but I was saying you know
that all-american like Oh like I was I
was really hoping you guys would go that
route so I didn't like it
yeah but you didn't we all sort of went
with like burly believably gritty dude
so I got a readjust strategy here a
little bit Ryan Hurst spent a lot of
time on Sons of Anarchy and a leather
jacket and we saw him hit just a lot of
important Wolverine character beats we
saw him hit betrayal we saw him hit his
little rainy Limit Breaks and big hints
of berserker rage but also sort of that
warm side you could sort of see him
nurturing a Jubilee if the if the Disney
movies chose to sort of jump right into
it you both evolve our green friendship
bride
okay Brian I don't think you want your
Wolverine to have a tender spot I think
that unless it is a Wolverine movie and
he needs to have an emotional arc that
we just want to see Wolverine beat [ __ ]
up and we want to see Wolverine smolder
and nobody smolders better than my man
well I will say you did today pick an
actor who even though we've seen actors
jump Chris Evans jump from Fantastic
Four to Captain America we've seen
actors go from combo combo you're
literally taking someone who was in an
x-men movie and making him an x-men yet
again that might be a little off
throwing I'm also Oscar Isaac is a great
actor I'd love to see in my next movie
he needs to play the smoldering
romantics I think he's a great
Nightcrawler I think you got a great
Nightcrawler they're not straight on ice
on camera hours my man has been seen
wearing basically the Wolverine outfit
y'all but Ron's got to find out he's
been like I want to say 23 total minutes
of screen time in his career that's a
lot of screen time soulless okay you
know I'll be honest I I was really gonna
lay in the Oscar Isaac but the choice of
pick with the beard I was like hmm but
that's it I I don't think the you know
you're both sort of mentioned they but
they can sort of both buff up and get
ripped I don't want to necessarily buff
up ripped Wolverine Wolverine needs to
be sort of stout and strong fat and
that's kind of what Ryan Hurst is
already leaning into the photo from
bullhead think the guy that doesn't look
like he got strong from CrossFit but the
guy who just looks like he got strong
because he like had to carry like a
mattress out of his ex-girlfriends
apartment over and over again
have you seen inside Llewyn Davis it
comes back to Oscar Isaac here's the
thing Oscar Isaac is an he's fantastic
and as a Wolverine I think he'd be very
interesting but I also think you guys
I'm gonna bring up the argument that
happened last week two guys who are
little they're not Wolverine needs to be
a little there the great thing about
what Wayne is in a high school full of
teenagers he was always 35 years old
but the fact of the matter in the cast
of greens he was look
look at the first on Candy's oldest
house compared to everybody else the
Jean Grey stuff is creepy also
considering the fact that he was like a
hundred what do you started getting into
Jean Grey we got some Twilight stuff
going on there but the thing about it to
me is we're also talking about movies
that probably one get made for another
two or three years at this point both of
these actors are gonna be mid-40s near
and 50 if not older and start if T ever
stopped Hollywood Cameron from letting a
white guy play a younger attractive lead
amongst a much younger cast I don't
think it's an issue for tech movies I
just wanna say one more thing about
Oscar Isaac please y'all seen
annihilation right he was basically
brain dead like you know just a total
zombie alien spoiler whatever like husk
of a man the entire time and homeboy
still couldn't get it so her love for
him was what propelled her to the third
act climax love not goodness I'm saying
that if he could be what we need in the
Wolverine if somebody who is going to be
very reserved so that all of America can
project their fantasies on him and try
to figure out like why are you so
mysterious what is he thinking
I think the romantic key to over in
limited to place myself in the shoes of
a lady for one moment and I've seen what
women want several times Julia so I am
more than capable of doing this is you
want a little bit of danger with that
crush like Oscar Isaac is like you know
he's like sort of an obvious pick for
like I like that dude but like Ryan hurt
that's the dude where you're like I
don't know he might get in a bar fight
if we go on a date but I can't why they
don't have the name recognition that
Oscar Isaac has well marble is good
about I think picking both like actors
that you've heard of and going like oh
but then picking like a Chris Hemsworth
who you might have seen him in one or
two things and then their breakout is
this marble thing that they did their
marbles pretty good about that you
forget that this is Disney Disney don't
give they do not care
so Disney is going to do what Disney
does no but that's more my name on it
put a name on it
well that's thing Marvel's Marvel's
since being owned by Disney which is
around Ironman
- I know Ironman - was paramount but I
think that at that point does need
already bought in them
I think post Iron Man - we're still
getting like unknown interesting TV
actors and foreign actors Disney once
Disney bought Marvel they didn't start
jamming it full of big but I'm saying
that the Disney Fox merger I think is
going to just open up this gauntlet of
like we don't care anymore we're not
going to try and like you know find a
breakout star we're just going to try
and sort of recycle what we've already
had because the bike is gonna let that
happen
we have three very different compelling
choices but what's rapping in the
closing arguments Julia why don't you
why don't you give us your closing on
Oscar Isaac first Wolverine as I've said
needs to be horny for everyone okay
I've said this several times in many
different junctures that's kicked out of
comic-con comic-con Isaac as I mentioned
he stole the show in suburbicon he's
like you know really the savior for a
lot of different movies like the one
person that you know is going to show up
to work and like give it his all he
comes from the stage so he understands
what acting with a capital A is so I
think that he's going to tap into some
like imagined backstory for a Wolverine
and like really do some actor Lee actory
[ __ ] but then I think also in the fact
that he's going to be horny for everyone
as I've mentioned you know he has a way
of acting very nuanced and very you know
reserved and usually when that happens
from the female gaze when a actors being
very reserved they project you know what
they feel they think what they mean and
what I'm saying is that this Wolverine
movie is going to need to appeal to
women and it's going to that's going to
be the most deciding factor for me so so
that's my closure of it right Oscar
Isaac Oscar Isaac Cameron I think for me
I think we got eight Wolverine movies
already even when the ones not called
Wolverine were Wolverine movies I think
if you cast a Chris Chris Isaak's Chris
is
if you cast an oscar i6 as wolverine i
think you're gonna get another Wolverine
movie Matthias Curtis has a thing about
him that x-factor
he can blend into both being the lead
but also being part of an actual
ensemble not taking over the movie being
slightly a different kind of actor an
unknown actor and also the fact of the
matter is people haven't saying for a
while they wanted Tom Hardy's Wolverine
ain't doing that he's doin venom I just
gave you Dutch Tom Hardy as far as
you're gonna go oh I did you better
believe it
you're welcome Fagin as far as your guy
looks it looks good for the part some of
those tattoos one looked like a Blair
Witch tattoo and I just can't buy that
Wolverine would be into the Blair Witch
long could he get a fact check wasn't
wearing a fan of Blair which had a
number of mystical encounters
notwithstanding his dealings with the
hand so I could definitely see you know
some weird issue that he'd have magical
tattoos that point aside you know I
think I think Wolverine has to fit a
very certain kind of tough the the Dutch
guy looks like he'd look way too good in
one of those like sleeveless hoodies
from Urban Outfitters and like that to
me like disqualifies him immediately
from being the Wolverine Ryan Hurst
again in Sons of Anarchy I think he
really he really showed his range and
why he'd be a good fit for Logan he's
also the next villain in The Walking
Dead sort of this like sort of grizzled
woodsy sort of Dredd guy of a character
so I think he just he has the resume
that's just sort of a natural
progression to this and and finally if I
could bring some visual aids into this
stand I don't think there's anything
Wiggly in the butt okay jte bring a
picture number one
that's what Vereen he's short he's hairy
he's mad he just killed Xavier picture
number two go they're very short smoking
cigars picture number three a little
hairy son of a gun picture before that's
an actual Wolverine
he's named for now picture number five
go look like the perfect Bend I agree I
don't feel like Joe shared that
information with the class so I'm gonna
as judge I'm throwing that evidence out
in this Court
guys this was a I feel like you all
picked very good choices one before I
announced my pick what lon
how are we looking on the facts first of
all we got it we got a deal with our
friend Matias the pronunciation of his
name I've been a short as Matias cone
arts he is Belgium not Dutch we gotta
get off the Dutch train the hell chicken
that Tom Hardy point though he recently
appeared in red Sparrow may have been
the recent film but this did not come up
during the round but I'm bringing it up
anyway he is also a graffiti artist who
works under the pseudonym zenith I just
thought that would be helping he's in
the comics clearly we got alright this
was very close Julie he really sold me
on Oscar Isaacs virility I believe that
he can get it if anybody wants to tweet
at me who can get it I'm happy to weigh
in you sold me on that unfortunately
that was not the question so it was
between imperative Joe can be a question
who can get it let's see your picture
every other day but as far as overall
Wolverine facts as far as telling me who
would hit the beats well physique etc I
feel like Joe tied their their choice
more most closely to the character why
they would work what from their past
work would indicate so I'm gonna side
with Joe but I'm only one third of the
equation one what are your thoughts Wow
everybody everybody had pretty good
arguments if these were all interesting
choices I don't think anybody picked
like a predictable that guy who was dead
you know everybody thinks that guy
should be Wolverine so I enjoyed and
gently see to it Cameron I thought
besides the sort of x-factor
sir he's got a certain something I can't
put my finger on it a little bit more
than that so I sort of was going his way
so we really can done to Joe versus
Julie for me and yeah I don't know I
felt like a lot of Joe's argument just
came down to the here physically he kind
of looks like well Ray's hairy and burly
and all those things but I thought Julie
made a better case for why as an actor
Oscar Isaac would really sink into this
role so I'm Julia all right so one for
Julia Danielle what say the people the
people with 60% say Ryan Hurst 24% for
Oscar Isaac and then 14%
it's still telling me that it's not
scone arts but they all think it's
different things
Matias skeeball let us know does not
carry Joestar with the people's vote in
my vote you carry the point everyone
nothing Joe James Cameron was gonna do
it here Bob Hoskins he wanted Bob
Hoskins to do pure physicality I forgot
the dink means diabologizer Scott
Eastwood
Daniel Radcliffe came up a lot because
apparently did something very funny Don
Wired's that I have not seen yet
I'm John Krasinski but one that I found
really interesting I don't know if I
agree but it's the like the most out of
the box when I've heard very cheesy boy
on Twitter says Joshua Jackson from
Fringe he only mentions fringe but we
know what whose general Jackson is could
pull off a sweet angry wolf man in my
opinion he's Canadian born and an
amazing dramatic actor plus he's a bit
of an outsider improve would provide a
fresh and different take on the classic
x-men all right guys the affair round
one in the books let's go on to round 2
I know if you know this but everything
is awesome again because the lego movie
2 opens this weekend what I believe
we've done this for a while but we added
a twist
what is the all-time best animated
sequel however there is a caveat the Toy
Story trilogy is disqualified there have
been we've argued it too much too many
it's too easy to be quite frank it's
like talking about reality is it quite
the quadrilogy well let's see we'll find
out so accepting Toy Story 2 and Toy
Story 3 what is the all-time best
animated sequel and this time we're
starting with Julia I mean mine is quite
frankly the most obvious answer so I'd
be surprised if you guys even formed an
argument against me oh you wait I'm
saying to baby so if we're you know
disqualifying the other Pixar sequels
then I'm gonna go with the second best
other Pixar sequel and yeah it was also
one of my favorite movies from last year
well there you go Julia with Prescott
Incredibles to Cameron to me a sequel is
not just repeating the beats of the
first film again and putting a little
bit of a little bit of a lime twist on
it you actually have to push the story
forward and I think that's why I'm going
with my pick which is americantale
Fievel goes west talk about that in a
minute yeah alright americantale Fievel
goes west
Joe Stark I'm glad you know sort of
Cameron made my opening statement for me
I agree a sequel should should push a
story and a bigger bolder more beautiful
place and that's why I am arguing How to
Train Your Dragon 2 the second in the
How to Train Your Dragon series hmm with
the third one hitting theaters soon as
well exactly it's a golden time for
animated sequels guys fight it out three
good movies these are three good movies
is the best one first time the first
thing I want to talk about is just the
the jump and quality you know obviously
CGI gets better and you know obvious
that sort of a no-brainer but just
looking at the artistry
in this movie it's just an absolutely
gorgeous movie to look at not only is
this is the animation perfect you know
the sky heck everyone's beards are just
little works of art in themselves but
Roger Deakins actually oversaw the
visuals and composed help compose you
know shots and how they how they
approach sort of the the DP for for this
project it's visually absolutely
beautiful gorgeous looking movie what I
will say that makes yeah Incredibles
choose such a standout in this category
is that there is integrity just
radiating out of every single pore of
this movie I am you know the biggest
piece of evidence for that is that they
didn't rush the sequel after the big
success in the first movie you know
DreamWorks historically has you know
been kind of playing both hands with
their features and TV series so at the
same time that how to train your dragon
was becoming a hit they were like
working immediately on the series
version of it and trying to get the
other sequel down the pipeline so I feel
like that cheapens the integrity overall
of what kind of story they're gonna tell
you guys both threw shade Incredibles -
and your opening statements two things
number one why ruin perfection we really
loved the world the music the design of
the characters the voice acting that
just felt so real for all of that we
loved that world we want more of that
well but I would say that it does
progress the story because now we have a
gender role-reversal so it's a very
feminist tale for young women to see
this you know a superhero woman going
into the workforce and you know being
able to be fallible - as well as being
this triumphant figure and that we
explored entitled loose ends with the
first one with Jack Tech and you know I
do feel like it offers us into the next
chapter and it's just a joy and I think
also the fact that Brad Bird himself was
like I'm not gonna do it until it's
right I'm not gonna do it until it's
right and then finally was right and it
got 93% of Rotten Tomatoes I mean I
would hate to read off the percentages
that your movies got on Rotten Tomatoes
but I have
right here Fievel got 45% hmm uh-huh
yeah granted that was you know before
run to me this is really picking up
speed and what that means I'm driving
got 92 so I'm still above you get out so
let me talk about I'll talk about Rotten
Tomatoes very briefly very quickly so
think around tomatoes to get a pass to
get a thing is basically generally
critics gave you not a good review a
pass review to have a 93
you could have ninety-three percent of
the critics go see and you get a 93 that
is still a big old tomato but that
generally means you didn't make that
much of a controversial hard-hitting
movie that may upset people people are
like this was generally pleasing I'm
gonna give it a tomato with the Fievel
goes west was too divisive for its time
a little bit so the thing about American
sale beyond being a play on words the
first one was of the American stories
about immigrants coming to America and
dealing with their immigration mostly
they were telling story about Russian
Jews using the mice as the parable word
went on my mind as the kind of allegory
allegory for it
the sequel then continues that story but
also talking about the other side of
America using fievel mousekewitz as the
character and it's not just let's just
do it again in the West because there's
no wild burp who in it's Jimmy Stewart's
last role actually the last thing he did
before he passed away was wild Burt no
it doesn't make you good but what also
doesn't make Incredibles too good is by
because it's not a sequel it's the
second season to a sitcom which is
basically like and I think it makes the
characters look dumb because again not
counting about 14 years later yes that's
when the movie came out the movie is
supposed to be taking place timeline
wise within the film right after the
events of the first film it takes it
starts right after the first one ended
so therefore the character should
probably be a little bit smarter than
like oh here's these mysterious people
who are going to separate the family but
we only want one of the family members
that's it just you it's like it is
literally the first film I guess trust
me yes it repeats the beats of the first
one but go ahead
let you guys fight for me mr. mom
already did all of it Incredibles to
like leans too close to the first movie
but I think Fievel goes west while
charming on its own I think goes way too
far away from from americantale
and goes full-on just like here's a
delightful cartoon movie about a mouse
cowboy and sort of loses some of the the
emotional weight and allegory from the
first one I'm gonna dog pile on that I
would say that that your argument for
the allegories that they were laying out
is more true to the first one and it is
to the second one I think the only
reason why you're saying the second one
today is because it is cloaked in
nostalgia and you are a 90's kid at
heart yeah let's do this I think the
only reason you got incredible hogs
Incredibles 2 is simply because the
gender role-reversal but ignoring a lot
of the other issues Incredibles
franchise is my favorite superhero and
that's great I will also say the whole
idea that Brad Bird waited till the
right amount of time cuz he said no a
lot and now he finally said yes also
because Tomorrowland bombed crazy bad
and it was like I gotta go to this other
thing that I know people really want and
will help my career again because
otherwise I'm in director trail Andrew
Sullivan had to do the same thing right
after John Carter said no until he had a
bomb and suddenly said you know how to
train your dragon goes full Empire
Strikes Back for what should have just
been a very simple like easy kids movie
they they aged all of the characters
they push them forward in their lives
and their maturity where they you know
where they are as people it takes on a
lot more like tougher themes with as
with the situation with his parents and
their strange meant and sort of the
weirdness of mixing of getting a family
back together we we lose beloved main
characters yeah and that's my bigger
swings and it land
sorry nor can I also add that the fact
that How to Train Your Dragon went
beyond the second installment so now
it's a multiverse you know kind of thing
going on I think that it undercuts the
importance and the significance of How
to Train Your Dragon 2 whereas we know
like the series and yeah I know no I'm
saying that in How to Train Your Dragon
3 what's coming out like that that makes
it less important to you know it being
this like really powerful sequel where I
feel like we know this is Jedi doesn't
lessen the impact of Empire for me even
though there's so many bears but the
argument is not it's not about a trilogy
well I would say and I love how to train
your dragon to my issues with it though
as I will say the minute and I think at
the end of the day it's still like you
know a kid's cartoon you're gonna hit
certain tropes of course that happen and
in kids cartoons but the minute the bomb
showed up I was like oh the dad's dead
because Jeffrey Katzenberg could not
escape some of the Disney trappings he
loved to do in the 80s and 90s
I knew that Dad was dead the second the
mom showed up and I feel like you do
have a little bit again it's we're doing
kind of the story from the first one but
different it's like oh he's got a
strained relationship with his dad and
now the sequel it's a strained
relationship with the mom and that's my
thing with Bible is at the end of the
day I do appreciate that The Incredibles
is still about a family no one died it
wasn't like Jack Jack Jack Jack's deal
with me right now I'm giving a plus to
Incredibles 2 by the fact that they
don't kill a family member that they
don't follow so those traffic's they
don't try and darken it up by what I
like about Fievel is that Fievel does
continue the story of about this family
but Incredibles 2 does and pushes the
story forward still being about Fievel
but you're also following the story of
the sister I think John Cleese's
caterwaul is an awesome villain and the
fact that the relationship between
Fievel and Dom DeLuise is character who
that name went right Tiger grows and
continues a lot of Disney sequels and
this is not Disney movie but a lot of
cartoon sequels wreck and Ralph - the
characters learned a lesson
I gotta learn it again which is a little
bit my problem with Incredibles - it's
the characters learn to be a family unit
now some
left they got to learn to be a family
unit Fievel goes west doesn't run into
any of that stuff family stories are
it's constantly being you know pulled
apart and then brought back together
over renewed for season two is literally
a wheel that they spin and go and it
goes west now I don't know who cares on
the other good sequel avoids those
trappings of like oh maybe the story
beats feel the same is they took it in
such a crazy weird different direction
with cowboy trend that having the mid
early 90s or whatever Incredibles is
staying true to what incredible to do
they know that their audience cares
about the family they're gonna give them
the family [ __ ] Cameron I will allow
you to respond but also this will be a
closing argument and the elites get to
do the same
everybody has brought up points it's
everything else so this briefly in
summary please tell me why your pick is
is the best out of these two not
necessarily what's wrong with the other
two and why were yours versus to me a
sequel like it needs to be a new story a
different story not a retread of the
story that came before
just hit again if you do that you're
just getting a bottle episode of a TV
series
I think Fievel goes west is a different
story it's a new story it does hit
familiar tropes but not familiar tropes
of animated films it hits familiar
tropes of westerns and the things that's
paying homage to it's one of the few Dom
Blue sequels that Dom blows wasn't
involved in and wasn't a giant piece of
card and honestly to me I think having
Jimmy Stewart in it
a person who was known for his westerns
as his last role is a Western animated
or not even if he's playing a burping
dog is something that's worth noting and
I think it's a great movie if you go
rewatch it just ry is How to Train Your
Dragon to better than these two first
there's no hidden penis drawn into How
to Train Your Dragon 2 and there's a
there's a really famous one in five will
goes West them no its rescuers its
rescuers I think no no it's Fievel goes
west I you want it for two minutes
before the show started today it's in
there for two minutes keep talking bring
him down how to train your dragons highs
beat the highs of these other two movies
that the flying sequences are absolutely
gorgeous I put them up against any
live-action movies
sequences any planet earth documentaries
sequences of things flying through the
sky they're absolutely stunning and
beautiful and breathtaking I think the
action is fantastic also hiccup has a
flying sort of a flame sword that's
really dope Lynch words are always great
I think toothless is such a phenomenal
character and they keep they really just
lean even more into his relationship
with hiccup and I think the fact that he
doesn't talk gives it like a really cool
like Miyazaki sort of my neighbor totoro
kind of vibe which I really like there's
themes of empathy of being stronger
together and again there's no that we
know of hidden dicks alright no hidden
dicks that's TBD but also the empathy
thing does his research but also empathy
Giulia Incredibles - why is it better
than the other - there's no hidden dicks
and How to Train Your Dragon 2 but there
is a hidden monster that we wouldn't
know was a monster until the internet
told us I'm of course talking about one
of the voice actors of how to train
every cast even the third one props do
you had a trainer nevermind
Jimmy Stewart known for his westerns I'm
a little curious about that I I'm not
quite sure the other movies an entire
argument praising Incredibles - without
talking about the viral New Yorker
review from Anthony Lane in which he
gets so horned up for misses and cred
this old critic from a very snooty you
know refined source got so horned up
that's what this movie did to him
and I think that is what part of what
makes it one of the best animated
sequels of all time you know they tried
to hide dicks in your movie if they
didn't need eye dicks because the dicks
were in the theater movie have a theme
park ride I rest my case I think there
is a final thing at Universal Florida
there's a walk around character and you
know it that time one eye so many odd
questions tips just start just start
wherever there is a hidden dick in
Fievel goes west I don't know how can
zoom into my screen Marin see that is
true okay Stuart wasn't a lot of
westerns he is known for his westerns
Destry rides again the man who shot
Liberty valance a man from Laramie naked
spur there's a lot of there's a lot of
good ones that are well-known I think
we've coined the term the Fievel verse I
can't find it anywhere
I have a little bit of Anthony lanes New
Yorker is it just me or does mrs.
incredible kind of look like Anastasia
in Fifty Shades of Grey you know the
girl in the Red Room with the whips and
all and daddy just rested his Cooley
soda firmly in his lap and like mr.
incredible tried very hard to think of
algebra
sounds like it most incredible moments
in print media than I've witnessed in
the last five years okay with three
films effects alright one why don't you
just roll that right into what did you
think of the truck a lot of arguments
fly we took a lot of different
dimensions and Julia was I felt like
there were a lot of good arguments
against Incredibles to kind of going
over the top with the TV show really
strong final argument I feel like
overall for Fievel goes west movie I
have not seen in several decades some
gave this one camera I am going a
different way I felt that Cameron
Cameron had had very strong central
argument he was he was a one or it for
me it was a one issue argument as far as
not being a retread a news story but I
need I feel like I need more than just
that this wasn't quite enough they're
there for me so for me this between
Julie and Joe I will agree with you on
that there's a lot negative brought up
against Incredibles too but I'm not
gonna let the volume of that negativity
sway me because I felt like Julia was
ready with the counter-argument for
everything you know it's a game of facts
it's a game of passion and I got the
most passion for their pick from that
round I feel like you know Joe had the
look and he had the themes but I mean if
we're talking passion and who can argue
their choice the best that for me was
Julia so I'm gonna side with Julius
that's one for Cameron one for Julia
Danielle what's say the people
Incredibles 2 with 22% americantale
fella goes West were 20% well that means
it's a three-way tie and Danielle you
get to be the tiebreaker to be a person
I have to agree and I'm also going for
Julia but for different reasons I did
like the passion obviously Julia cracks
me up every time she's on here but she
was the most well-researched out of all
the fighters when it came to her movie
and the other two movies and sometimes
you know I want to run a reward a good
book nerding so I'm giving that up to
Julia there we go alright so that means
thank you going into round 3 it is 1
point for Jill one point for Julia
Cameron trying to take this to a
tiebreaker at three-way tie breaker so
many moments in the zoone second choice
yeah so many moments a Superbowl not
many but we did get a teaser for the
twilight zone during the Superbowl and
honor of Jordan peels reboot which I'm
very much looking forward to this is for
nerds this for some sci-fi mystery nerds
what classic Twilight Zone episode would
make the best movie and for the benefit
of the viewers it doesn't have to be a
detailed synopsis but as you're pitching
if you could give everyone a brief
rundown of what is a in the episode that
you're pitching and Cameron since you
are in the third chair you go first
so I am choosing the classic episode the
eye of the beholder for those who do not
know you might know visually the show it
is commonly referred to as the pig face
episode it is the episode where a woman
is talking about wanting to get facial
reconstruction surgery so she can look
like everybody else if she could look
normal
her head is bandaged for the majority of
the episode until the very end when it's
revealed she'd had a surgery and it just
didn't work they've done these surgeries
so many times it's never worked and it's
a real cheese by modern standards even
back then too gorgeous and then we see
what everyone else looks like this is
mostly shot through point of view that
everyone else in the world has pig faces
and then you hear the classic Rod
Serling narration where he says the
title of the episode
why don't you give us a few bars that's
all I know right now just went to bill
haters Vincent Price there's a good SNL
sketch with noir McDonald about this
episode look it up it's noted it's very
weird all right Joe what what have you
picked I went with an episode called
purple Testament and this is it's set in
World War two in the Philippines and
it's basically it's about an American
soldier who is able to see an aura
around someone who is going to die soon
and so he sort of feels this weight on
the battlefield of who can I save who do
I have to let go so that I can save
those people how much of a difference
can I make in their lives does this not
you know is this knowledge of burden is
this knowledge helpful and yeah I just
think that's a really cool sort of non
spaceship II sci-fi theme to wrap your
head around especially for a for a war
movie so alright and Julia what episode
of you picked mine is of course the
Twilight Zone classic Terra 50,000 feet
you know this I feel recap people that
have-not did you just have a shudder
moment I did it's scary this has been
parodied many time in pop culture
through like Simpsons family Guy etc but
basically Williams NAT NAT nur flames
NAT greed on Twitter do you follow him
on Twitter he's so funny but they still
have CW shows yeah he is on a plane he
thinks he sees a gremlin on the wing and
nobody else sees it so it becomes this
very like you know sort of shutter
island'
II like psychology like am I seeing
things am I going crazy kind of thing
which I felt the troilus time did so
well as I mentioned this has been
parodied many times in pop culture so I
feel like the general public will be
wanting waiting for the modern
equivalent of this story alright so
three
soda and again keep in mind the sitting
just about how good the story is but
it's why this would make the best
feature film fight it up so a question
when does yours take place mine takes
place in present time okay so could the
person not just take a photo of the
gremlin on their phone and go stewardess
darling would be able to bypass that
pretty easy interesting that you're
poking holes in mind before staining
yours I'm just curious because I have an
answer for you I think that it would be
very modern and very fun and very hip
and I think that the general public
would really enjoy for Terry
terror at 50,000 feet to be upped up
some feet and that it takes place on
Elon Musk's Tesla in space baby I don't
know is it space dust that's all it's
the movie life still sinking so I like
mine because um I don't think a lot a
lot I don't think there's a lot of
variation in in though in the wars honor
we got Overlord recently with sort of
this which was sort of the the India
Sambi thing I think you could do this in
order to or you could do it in modern
day I think that the story sort of
remains the same but I like the idea of
doing this sort of moral quandary
thriller story within the trappings of
you know of an epic war movie of your
black hawk downs or your Saving Private
Ryan or something like that how does a
movie like that change where it's where
a guy can you know who's who's who's
sending people to do these missions to
send and I can literally see okay you're
coming back here coming back you're not
coming back you're not coming back so
you know what I haven't seen the others
over well so he knows right away the
whole way I see he like yeah it's like
he sort of sees it you know they're sort
of like it you know it's not like you're
gonna die the next week it's it's pretty
imminent but like what goes into that
decision-making how does that affect
like the stress of a soldier I just
think that that's really really kind of
a cool thriller to go down I think that
that would be a cool thriller I also
think
would be a huge bummer that the American
public does not want to be bummed right
now I think instead they want to see you
know a goofy little test love floating
around in space and also to answer your
questions of why can't they just take a
photo yes this is where I'm gonna blow
your sci-fi mind photo right they're
gonna take a photo and it'll be like I
got it and then when they look at the
photo the gremlins go muskan they're
like ela did you see I sent you the
photo he goes so dependent on that one
weird little twist I don't know how you
maintain that for like a 90 minute
feature and the moment that people see
it I'm the dog pilot and the moment that
people see their would be like oh yeah
this one one of the most point where I
do think people will be whoever you cast
in that role but people will wait for
their iconic read up there's something
on the way we'll do a schedule to be
like okay terror in 50,000 feet
auditions take one and it will just be
all of the people that never get
featured in primetime on us and now
because Alec Baldwin is just
monopolizing to me I so here's the
answer that I think the thing is is like
a little bit your sounds like a putting
together a final destination and
Overlord Overlord did not do very well
great movie did not do very well I would
say the argument about how can you
maintain this it almost doesn't even it
sounds like what you took was the
gremlin and but other than that you have
to you have now Elon Musk is in this
movie it's now in space there's a degree
where it's like it doesn't even sound
like it doesn't even tell necessary like
an adaptation it just sounds like I took
the gremlin
I'm Argan Hollywood and we're all about
clippable content so this is a clickable
there I think for me I think that my to
me I think I would want to grab because
I think the idea of what is beauty and
what is interviewing something we're
always arguing about every couple of
years this comes back around about like
what is the beauty standard the fact
that this episode is still relevant if
people watch it today it's shown in like
English classes I've seen colleges teach
this exact episode so you're gonna do it
like a feature like a hardcore Henry
style I would no no I well to me I think
you do give it to an interesting
director the director I'd pick is Karyn
Kusama who just did destroyer you picked
someone who does Chandra she did an
interesting thing with Jennifer's Body a
movie that was sadly under scene but I
think people are rediscovering now ten
years later about beauty standards in
horror I think if you give her something
like this and I think with a movie and
look she's controversial [ __ ] right now
there's no denying it but if you pick
someone like a Scarlett Johansson like
what they did with her where it's just a
voice that can compel an audience enough
to drag through what something is a
movie yes I think the idea of like oh if
you just do a hardcore Henry we just do
this to me it's not necessarily the
entire movie takes place in first person
because the entire episode doesn't take
place in first person but there's gonna
be that mix of that and I think you can
also do a hospital not a drama but like
a hospital set spooky thing where
people's faces aren't shadows you give
it to an interesting director you get a
strong enough writer and we didn't say
but if Jordan Peele like let's say he's
involved as a producer now like the show
does so well they're gonna make movies
now off some of the famous episodes I
think you got a hell of a movie I
disagree I think that's if you don't
agree closing argument by Julia why
don't you actually I think Joe closed
last last night no you close last last
time right now Joe I let you close on
the Julie you can close okay the thing I
like it's hard to doing any of these
they're they're classic classic Twilight
all right episodes they're all and so I
think it's a question of like adapting
into a feature-length film I think I
think sort of the building paranoia of
terror can can be adapted into into a
feature-length film and I think purple
purple Testament definitely can sort of
following the arc of a soldier you know
on a battlefield and watching all these
sort of pressures build around them and
so watching the psychological
really digging into the psychological
cost and like really kind of wearing
that as a on your sleeve as a theme of
your war movie can definitely be adapted
really interestingly interestingly into
a feature film whereas I think I don't
know I I have the beholder it's like a
quick like yeah I got it and I don't
know how you necessarily like hold back
the twists for a three-act feature film
you know for something that's kind of
like it it's great for what it is it's
20 minutes or 22 minutes you're in and
out and boom and like you said Rod
Serling comes in and goes in a world
where forever all right my incoherent
clothes all right I just want to see
something really quick about I have the
beholder you mentioned a lot about like
beauty standards sort of being reversed
or sort of rearranged and through the
sci-fi I I think that that could easily
go easily easily go the heavy-handed
route and then you just have a new dove
campaign and women take that campaign
always in hate it so that's 50 percent
of your audience that you've just lost
okay now the director no sorry I'm sorry
I don't get paid as much as you so I
really want to you know have the floor
so I think I'm gonna go do post after
this
[Laughter]
I want to say the tariff 50,000 feet as
I mentioned it has been parodied many
times the pop culture that means that
people are waiting for whatever their
take is going to be I think it can be
really fun to involve elion Elon Musk in
a way and I think it could be also very
forward to involve space itself and you
know sort of add an element of gravity
into it I also want to say even though
that doesn't have a direct link to my
closing argument about specifically
terrible 50,000 feet but when I was a
senior in high school my senior film was
based on Twilight Zone episode perchance
to dream and it basically is a story
about a woman who goes to a doctor I'm
sorry a man who goes to the doctor and
he's talking about nightmares that he
keeps having about a cat and that's it
and I decided that that was going to be
my senior film so I feel very
passionately about Twilight Zone and it
was also mainly just to [ __ ] around and
black and white cinematography because I
was so angry so don't [ __ ] with me when
it comes to that Twilight Zone episode
is called nightmare at 20,000 feet I
think is that the treehouse of horror
priority from this infant terror at five
and encounter and say that Billy
Patterson wrote so much today Williams
just geez oh so this shows hardwood
actually care no road Raider three we
had a really great one but I liked which
would have been my pick too since he
said that camera had already went with
his so he got to take time enough at
last would have been mine too you got a
lot of great post my sleep in film and
would get more time to get to know his
family and his frustrations before the
final scene also from last from last
round are
from Laura phenomenon made a great meme
of Dead Poets Society that you guys just
have to look at because it's fantastic
did she tweet it did she did tweet
identified on there um and lastly it is
it is a viewer who really loves Twilight
zones and this is where their favorite
shows birthday today so happy birthday
cosmic crap I will weigh in first I
think that of all the pitches and I
think it was actually helped by a
counter-argument because somebody in
referencing Joe's idea I think it might
have been Cameron said that sounds like
a huge bummer I mean that was the
twilight zone it was huge bummer the
series I don't think that's out of
character and then I say maybe usually I
don't I think that the other ones just I
was not on board with with Elon Musk and
Tesla the space there's a little too
scattered for me and the Pigface thing I
think it's a great talent but I never
really found heard what the movie was
gonna be I like Joe's movie pitch the
best and I feel like overall it just
came together for me more than the other
two so my vote is for Joe 1 what are you
thinking yeah I actually I believe I
agree with you I felt like Cameron they
really hit him hard on me is there
enough meat there I feel like I the
polder just works so perfectly as a
24-minute ever so especially cuz you
can't see their faces how would you do a
whole movie where you can't see most of
the characters faces mhm
then Julia is I thought it's an
interesting premise but I agree with a
lot of the counter-arguments pick both
everybody kind of we all know that's
where it's so it's been adapted so many
times have been priority so many times
I'm not sure there's enough tension
there whereas I thought Joe's came
together as like a complete pitch I
could see this becoming a like epic
scale war movie so I'm going with Joe as
well Joe star gets the point which means
with a by a score of 2 to 1 Joe and
Julia are moving on to the speed round
yeah say it's another goose egg that's
fine apologies care about anything
just love the Cameron for coming in as
the Joestar someone had to cancel and
everyone was awesome enough to take over
the world now all right guys so two to
one that means Joe you need two points
to win the game Julia you only need
three points to win the game so Jays got
a slight advantage but it's anyone's
game this how the speed round works I'm
gonna ask you a question you will have
the first person to speak will answer
first the second person to speak will
then go second you have 20 seconds to
make your man argument ten seconds for
counter-arguments long we'll be timing
you any questions yeah let's go to the
speed round
all right one of my favorite questions
ever 2019 officially now the year of the
pig it's about time what's the greatest
ever movie Pig Oh Jeff babe Oh Jeff okay
all right now if one one is so Joe with
okay Julia with babe Joe spoke first Oh
Joe 20 seconds when you begin speaking I
think okay as a character is is a
there's a really great technical
achievement it's a beautiful looking
character in this movie again you know
no dialogue no talking so everything
that you all the empathy that you have
towards this character has to come from
the face and from from from its body
movement I think that's just a really
great achievement from the from the
animators that they made this fully
realized character that you babies
amazing technical achievement and the
character achievement to the world of
anthropomorphic animals in film I think
that a true strength of an animal that
is like the main star in a live-action
movie which is really hard to do is that
they you know get our empathy and get
our sympathy and the fact that he turned
an ornery old farmer into a lovable
person Joe 10-second counter you babe
took on farmer owner eNOS but okay took
on the sis
some of how we treat animals as a whole
okhta made us look at some really really
hard truths that were even uncomfortable
within the context of the movie to look
at and maybe really deal with them
nobody remembers okhta everybody
remembers and says on the Reg that'll do
Pig that'll do it is in the common
vernacular and I can't even remember
anything from oka besides the fact that
that pig did look cool alright I'll go
first I will say that I feel like Joe
got a little too hung up in his opener
on technical achievement only at what
Judy was unable to hold in as long as
bringing in the character the fact that
it brings empathy I felt like the
counter-argument for Joe was much more
on the movie and this is about the pig
itself so my vote goes to Julie on that
round lawn what do you think yeah a
hundred percent agree I think I heard a
lot more compelling about specifically
the pig from Julia's argument about babe
all right you win this time because it's
high game to to Miss Piggy maybe I'm too
much of a snob but oh so so the parents
were spirited away summer dub I'm just a
little bit guys I hope you don't mind
there's a few things I just have to ask
we got the titles too we got potential
titles to some of the upcoming avatar
sequels this week what is a title that
would guarantee that you would pay to
see a sequel to avatar
[Laughter]
free parking is free parking Robert
Mullins closing arguments from Julia we
have avatar free parking and from Joe
Robert Miller's avatar Raul is closing
arguments Julia you spoke first so you
are on the clock first 20 seconds when
you start going to movies is really
expensive especially in LA especially in
LA it's really hard to find parking and
so anything that gets me out of the
house if it is enticing with a free
parking I'm gonna go and I'm just going
to sit and maybe and there's free
parking and free uber so I can take a
wheat gummy and just enjoy the worlds of
the nothing and just let it wash over me
like a cool soft rain Joestar free
parking doesn't guarantee a good movie
but imagine this just the Navi and a
rapt attention is robert muller and am
EXCI realize gorgeous 3d and then at the
end he gets on a big ol flying
pterodactyl thing just flies doesn't it
one thing that's really interesting
about the avatar universe is that the
first avatar movie was famous for
sparking disenchantment with a lot of
people that had then had to go to normal
real life and I feel like the rubber
Moeller last closing right minutes gonna
spark the same disenchantment
Joe one of the best things to come out
of the avatar phenomenon was terrible
tattoo so imagine the next time Oller
Tempe fans bodies will just be
absolutely incredible and will entertain
us for years to come well past that new
closing statement
I'm not going julia had me with her
opening argument because how many times
have you but we all been through the
pain of having and drive to the movie
theater cities I'm not sure if I lived
in you know like non LA environment if
that would really drive you there
where does Joe maybe like universally
who wouldn't want to watch Robert Muller
in a mech suit okay thank you I I tend
to agree that I Julia had a very
compelling argument but it is very
geographically specific to places that
don't already have ample free parking
and I think no matter what III think
even the president would want to see
Robert momentum exude I just think
that's a sight that we all would like to
see in general good way to get the
president's attention so he listens to
what Robert Mozer say live to me during
the movie what's happening in the cab
movie so I think for those reasons and
very little else okay I will also go
with Joe so Joe you get that point is
now game point for you Julia you can tie
it up with this one and it will go into
a sudden-death last point tiebreaker
winner eats Cameron all right what's a
good one here all right let's see
they're all good I'm sorry I want I did
not mean to imply that some of these I
could be in the middle of you know
[ __ ] nowhere and if somebody tells me
sorry if somebody tells me free parking
all taken this is appeal denied the
decision has been made
okay run Russian doll and happy deathday
to you both deal with real people with
sorry with people that really
based on a true story what a movie
character would you most want to see
have to relive the same day over and
over again so you are not reliving it
with them you have you have to watch
this movie character relive the same day
over and over again ad infinitum yes
and a compelling television right now
silence falls over to the studio dead
air fights may have been a mistake
issues this question estimated the
comedic ability I'm joking filling up
its vamping is what the industry term is
I still think Becky Lynch would make a
great Wolverine she got her face broken
and came back and wrestled two weeks
later that's amazing girls know me from
showgirls which day girls okay Julia
need an answer
the dude from The Big Lebowski the dude
from The Big Lebowski Nomi Malone versus
the dude always a good match up Joestar
you spoke first so your time will start
when you begin speaking there's such a
frantic psychotic nough Stu how Nomi
Malone approaches every day of her life
in the movie showgirls that if it just
went on repeat I think that her just
life would just end up going even
crazier she would just completely spin
out of control the moment she realized
what's going on she's already like has
to go further it's just gonna go nuts
and clearly off the rails but if Nomi
Malone is facing the same exact things
day after day after day she's going to
have the same exact reactions day after
day after day that's just a normal day
in the life for the dude like he is
non-plus all the time he is like exactly
out of five all of the time so him
repeating the same day is just him in
his life and do what you want to see
that everybody loves the dude the guy
that the dude was based on is like a
celebrity in some circles for some
[ __ ] reason
am i cussing too much a little bit but
sorry that guy's been cast
live show Joe I think the crux is this
day repeating is the sex and the hot tub
thing that's how many men probably gets
a yeast infection and she has to learn
that not a healthy thing to do in a hot
tub so then she has set to keep
repeating this day over plus that means
he sends champagne that champagne line
over and over again that the Big
Lebowski was based on The Big Sleep
which is a camper which means that there
are so many different paths that he can
tape because it is a mystery so what if
he doesn't go after the guy said took
his rug what if he just safe and then
you know has a normal day or what if
this what if that it is built for
choose-your-own-adventure
all right that was a great closing and I
will say I'm no physician but unless
because the day is repeating I don't
look like well I don't know the timing
work it will work out for know me to
learn her lesson is what I'm saying
Joe's counter-argument there I have no
medical expertise that's throwing that
out I think that Julie just had the
better argument for why the dude he easy
does it anyway the caper there's lots of
different ways that it can go I am gonna
go with Julia Danielle what did you say
as much as I want to see Nomi Malone do
her nails over and over I want to see
that push down the steps I there are
certain scenes I definitely don't want
to see III Julia's closing argument
about how it would be a great
choose-your-own-adventure because it's a
caper really sold that for me so I gotta
go with Julia yeah all right so it is
three to three back if you did young way
a little bit it's a great moment in
sports okay
three three final question I have two to
choose from I'm just gonna go with one
that's how the show works
bad boys might get its own spin-off TV
series called LA's finest yep from
spectrum cable there are the ones
they're gonna fund it straight world we
live in what not above gas station teeth
he's also a taxicab TV and it's bad boys
make it its own spin-off TV series
called LA's finest what other Michael
Bay movie should get its own TV show the
island Joe says alright b-roll of
deleted explosions yes Lana said are we
I'll leave that one to you right sure
I'm not familiar with Michael Bay's work
I mean I am and I'm not you can tell me
any movies and Michael Bay movie and I'd
go yeah alright well I think we just
have to acknowledge that you're starting
out with a handicap it's gonna be a bit
of a handicap Joe I mean it's you did
should be I guess Joe it's up to Joe
yeah will you allow it they all argue
again it's admissible to the island
versus b-roll of deleted explosions Joe
you spoke first you get to argue first
you know damn there's more to Michael
Bendis beer all about
I think that the island sort of can lend
itself to a to a series long a series
long sort of mystery of like what's
going on what's the there's so much
weird stuff going on here
as these people start to finally realize
that everything in the world around them
it is wrong and not what they knew and
sort of going on that journey with these
two characters will be interesting and
cool I think one thing that we learned
about the island is that he's not really
good at character film and he's not
really good at story he is good
explosions also what has been the number
one show that I feel in some ranking is
for decades America's Funniest Home
Videos b-roll of explosions is basically
America's Funniest Home Videos but like
the most high budget ever and if you've
ever been anywhere on YouTube you have
seen b-roll of explosions so you know
b-roll of explosions might be where the
money is on this but I maybe have some
hoverbikes and some sexual chemistry 42
leads and end up being clones dead
seconds Julian who did it in the hands
of somebody who's not a skilled
storyteller is basically just serenity
so basically what I'm saying is that
b-roll of explosions is the money it's
what he's good at it's going to be fiery
maybe Tony Cal's going to be in it it's
gonna be fine
alright the island versus be Rosa versus
Danielle what do you think despite
arguing with the handicapped Julia had
me at the beginning when she was really
managed to hammer in how you if you're
gonna do something when that director
you want to deal with there but I felt
like there wasn't a great counter to
when she mentioned of when she mentioned
that that's why an island series
wouldn't work so it's kind of good what
movie should Michael Bay turn into a TV
show then Julia would have sold me but I
feel like most of argument was Michael
Bay wouldn't do a good
but that wasn't the question the
question was just which Michael Bay
movie would make a good TV show on that
level I think Jo had the better argument
for the island then just b-roll of
explosions although I like the America's
Funniest Home Video example the gambit
failed suspect to me okay you know Jo
that America's I think he's got drifted
because I have to be honest - what
argument I responded to the most I
thought it was an unwinnable argument
that home video compared the Americas 20
some videos those high budget explosion
sounds like a really great TV show I
gotta give it to Julia those are the
circumstances under which the way I
think all the other losses were worth it
just for that one Joestar you'll be back
next week cold or something so shake it
off Cameron I don't know what to say I
would have gone Armageddon and give that
to Paul Scheer every week and do a
meteorite the oil crews got to go up
again they're like no
a show for me before we go Joestar
anything you want applause tell people
where they can find you make sure you're
following these two Julie Prescott
wonder that one of the funniest kindest
people I know we've been doing come
together for a long time are we met
because we were in a game of Thrones
comedy thing and we were Meera and Jojen
Reed together we literally how we met in
terrible low budget we can't afford
things Game of Thrones costumes okay
what super funny talented guy thanks as
always for pinch-hitting and coming in
we love having you here yeah just make
sure you following them Julie Prescott
the only Simpsons podcaster in the game
my co-host a leader tonight we also
wrote a Simpsons book which is available
at stores that sell books and places
online that sell books I'm so good that
isn't it's called a hundred things
Simpsons fans should know and do before
they die and the format is written by
Bill Oakley and Josh Weinstein former
show runners of The Simpsons and I'm
actually oppressed got all the things
awesome and Cameron Rice a jack of all
trades including as we learned today
most mates
EUCOM slash dress gaily and also go
check out my photo work instagram.com
/cam right Spota whatever camera photo
on instagram ID also i do a show in
hyper RPG called blood-curdling tales
from the loop it's like a horror e 80s
Twilight Zone II RPG show it's Cameron's
like a really really good storyteller
it's a fantastic show yeah I'm very good
as always
lon Harris Daniel Radford thank you for
holding it down
London Calling over there with the facts
and the memes thank you guys anything
you guys want a plug I just bought me on
Twitter at ello and s that's easy yeah
you can follow me on Twitter Daniel
Radford you can follow me on Instagram
and Danielle underscore Radford I have
patreon we talk about bad movies it's a
really good time hey awesome and as
always thank you for watching JT in the
booth Billy business with the producing
Ryan and pac-man on the socials and the
gears and whistles and everything else
and this has been quite a show
thanks for watching hi to mom and Maura
watching at home we'll see you next week
Hey
[Music]
you